GILBERT STRANG: OK,
it's time to move on
to second order equations.
First order equations,
we've done pretty carefully.
Second order equations
are a step harder.
But they come up in nature,
they come in every application,
because they include
an acceleration,
a second derivative.
OK, so this would be a second
order equation, because
of that second derivative.
I'm often going to have
constant a, b, and c.
We have enough
difficulties to it
without allowing
those to change.
So a, b, c constants, and
doing the null solution
to start with.
Later, there'll be a forcing
term on the right-hand side.
But today, for this
video, null solutions.
And the point is, now,
what's new is that there
are two null solutions.
So y null will be a
combination of e--
and they're both exponentials.
Having constant
coefficients there
means exponentials
in the solution.
So e to the sum
exponent, and another one
to a, hopefully,
different exponent.
Sometimes if s1 equals s2,
that'll be a special case
and we'll have a slight change.
But this is typical.
So we have two constants, c1
and c2, in the null solutions.
And we need two
initial conditions
to determine those constants.
So previously, for a first order
equation, we were given y of 0.
Now, when we have acceleration,
we give the initial velocity,
y prime of 0.
May I use prime as a
shorthand for derivative?
y prime of 0 is dydt, at 0.
So two condition will,
at the right time,
determine those two constants.
And just to say again,
so second derivative
will be y double prime.
And that represents,
in physics, it
represents acceleration-- change
in velocity, change in y prime,
is y double prime.
And in a graph of a function,
y double prime shows up
in bending of the graph.
Because bending is
a change in slope.
Bending is a change
in the slope.
And the slope is y prime,
the first derivative.
So to measure changes
in y prime, which
will bend the graph, my chalk
would be a tangent line.
But if that changes,
that gives us
a y double prime, a
second derivative.
OK, so I'm ready
for some examples.
And the first example-- the
most basic equation of motion
in physics and engineering,
I would say-- it's
called harmonic motion.
And b is 0, that's
the key point.
b is 0.
It's Newton's law.
And so a will be the mass m.
y double prime,
second derivative.
b is 0.
Later, b will be a damping term,
a friction term, a resistance
term.
But let's have that 0.
So we're going to have
perpetual motion, here.
Plus the force-- so
this is Newton's law.
ma is f, f equal ma.
The force is proportional--
with a minus sign,
so it's going to come on this
side as a plus-- proportional
to y.
There's the equation.
No y prime term.
my double prime,
plus ky equals 0.
Starting from an
initial position,
and an initial velocity,
it's like a spring
going up and down, or a clock
pendulum going back and forth.
And we'll see it, so
it's going to be-- well,
we want to solve that equation.
So do we see solutions to that?
So if m and k were 1,
suppose m and k were 1.
I'm looking for a
second derivative plus
the function is 0.
Second derivative is
minus the function.
I immediately think of
sine t, and cosine t.
Sines and cosines, because
the second derivative--
the first derivative
of a sine is cosine.
The second derivative
is minus the sine.
It gives us the minus sign
here, the plus sign there, 0.
So the special solutions here
are y is-- this is the null.
I'm finding the null solution.
Is, let me call them
c1 times a cosine.
And now I have to figure
out the cosine of what?
I want the cosine to satisfy,
to be a null solution,
satisfy my equation.
Let me put it in.
If there's a square
root of k over mt.
And you have to
see that if I take
two derivatives of the
cosine, that will produce
minus the cosine, which I want.
And because of that, the chain
will bring out this square root
twice.
So it will bring out the factor
k over m for y double prime.
And that factor, k over
m, the m's will cancel
and I'll have the k
that matches that k.
It's a solution.
And the other solution
is just like it.
It's the sine.
Sine of this square
root of k over m, t.
That's worth putting
a box around.
That's what I mean by
free harmonic motion.
Something is just oscillating.
In rotation problems,
something is just
going around a circle
at a constant speed.
And notice, these are
not the same as those.
Cosines are related
to exponentials,
but not identical.
So I could write the answer
this way, using cosine and sine.
Or as you'll see, I can
write the same formula
using exponentials,
complex exponentials.
Everybody remembers
the big formula
that allows complex
numbers in here
is Euler's formula, that
the exponential of i omega t
is the cosine plus i
times the sine of omega t.
I'll write it again.
That's the solution.
It's got two null solutions.
They're independent.
They're different.
And we've got two constants.
Because our equation
is linear, we
can safely multiply by any
constant, and add solutions,
and they stay solutions because
we have a linear equation,
and 0 on the right-hand side.
Good.
Of course, we can't write
this square root of k over m
forever.
Let me do what everybody
does-- introduce omega.
It's omega natural.
The n here stands for
the natural frequency,
the frequency that
that clock is going at.
And that is the square
root of k over m.
So our equation, we could
rewrite that equation.
Let me rewrite that
equation to make it simple.
I'll divide by m.
No problem, to divide by m.
So then I have y
double prime, plus k
over m, which is
omega n squared,
the natural frequency squared.
y equals 0.
Let's put a box around that one,
because you couldn't be better
than that.
The constant a is 1.
The constant b is 0.
The constant c is a known
omega n squared, depending
on the pendulum itself.
OK, and the solutions then,
I'll just copy this solution.
y null is c1 cosine of omega nt.
Of course, omega n
is that square rood.
And c2 sine of omega nt.
Oh, well, wait a minute.
I can figure out
what c1 and c2 are ,
coming from the initial
conditions, right?
The initial conditions,
if I plug in t equals 0,
then I want to get
the answer y of 0.
The known initial
condition, the place
the pendulum started swinging
from, the place the spring,
you pull the spring
a distance y of 0.
You let go.
At t equals 0, so I'm
plugging in t equals 0, at t
equals 0, that's 0.
Forget the sine.
This is 1.
So I discover that
c1 should be y of 0.
Simple.
c1 is y of 0.
Because that gives me the
right answer, at t equals 0.
And what about c2?
Can I figure out c2?
Well, that's going to
involve the initial velocity,
the derivative, at t equals 0.
Because the
derivative of the sine
is the cosine, which
equals 1 at t equals 0,
the derivative of this
is the sine, which is 0.
So that when I'm looking
at y prime, the derivative,
I'm looking here at t equals 0.
And I want y prime of 0.
But I don't just
want y prime of 0.
Do you see that that doesn't
have the right derivative,
at t equals 0?
Because when I take the
derivative and omega
n-- that constant, you remember
that constant-- the derivative
of this will bring
out an omega n.
So I better have an omega
n down here to cancel it.
And now I've got it.
That tells me the
motion, forever and ever.
Energy is constant.
Potential energy
plus kinetic energy,
I could speak about energy.
But I won't.
That motion continues
forever, free harmonic motion.
OK, it goes on and on.
OK.
And again, I could write this in
terms of complex exponentials.
But I'm pretty happy
with that form.
It's hard to beat that form.
OK, so what else to do here.
First of all, we're going
to have cosine omega
t's for quite awhile.
I better draw the graph of
that simple, familiar function.
And so here's a graph
of cosine omega t.
So here's t.
Here's cosine of omega.
Here's 0.
Here's 2-- well, let
me see what I get.
So I go cosine of omega, cosine
of omega t is what I'm drawing,
not cosine t.
Cosine t would go 0 to 2 pi.
But I have cosine of omega t.
So cosine of omega t is
what I want to graph.
So it starts at 1,
and it comes back.
It drops, comes back
up, comes back to 1.
But what is this t final?
The period, this t is the
period of the oscillation.
It's the time it takes for
the swing to go up and back.
And what is that?
That would be-- so I'm
graphing cosine of omega t,
is what I'm graphing.
So omega t starts out
at 0, where t is 0.
And it goes up to-- so I want
omega t, when I get here,
this omega t should be 2 pi.
Right?
Then I've completed the cosine,
one rotation around the circle,
one movement of the
pendulum back and forth,
is in that picture now.
OK, so omega t is 2 pi, right?
Right.
The period is t.
I think of omega as
the circular frequency.
Omega is in radians per second.
That's the units.
And units truly are
important to keep track.
Omega, this is omega,
radians per second,
when I multiply by the
period, the t in seconds,
I get 2 pi radians.
OK now, in engineers
and in everyday use,
there's another frequency called
f, for frequency probably.
OK, so you should know about f.
And its frequency is in hertz.
So f is measured in hertz,
H-E-R-T-Z, named after the guy.
Not the tomato ketchup guy,
but-- oh, that's Heinz anyway.
Sorry about that.
Hertz -- not the car, that's
what I was trying to say,
but the German guy who
was involved, early,
with this stuff.
So what is f?
f times t is 1.
Instead of dealing with 2
pi, which count to radians,
the 1 just counts complete
loops, complete oscillations.
So f compared to know omega,
f is smaller by a factor 2 pi.
So f times t is
1. f is 1 over t.
Omega is 2 pi over t.
So putting these
together, all I'm saying
is, omega is 2 pi times f.
So when we say we're
getting 60 cycles-- so
that's what I would
measure tf in.
f would be in cycles,
is cycles per second.
One cycle, 2 pi radians.
This isn't big, heavy math.
But it's more important
than a lot of math,
just to get these
letters straight.
So there's capital
T, the period,
and two measures of frequency.
One is omega in
radians per second,
and the other is f in
full cycles per second.
So one is 2 pi times the other.
Good.
OK.
And we have this.
I think we've got the
key ideas here, then,
for unforced motion, pure
oscillation going on forever.
And let me just write
what I already mentioned.
A different way to express
yn would be with small c's, e
to the i omega nt.
And c2 e to the
minus i omega nt.
All I'm saying is that this
form, with exponentials,
is entirely equivalent to this
form, with cosine and sine.
That's form allows me two
constants, capital C1 and C2.
This form allows me two
constants, little one and c2.
And from that, I have this.
From this, I have this.
So we really do have
exponentials here.
And the key message is
that for pure oscillation,
those exponentials are pure
imaginary exponent, i omega nt.
OK, that's the best example,
the simplest example,
the first example.
Thanks.